مساء الخير يا جماعه الاول احب اشكر خالد
خالد رضاع ان هو عزمني ان انا اتكلم معاكم
النهارده فتكس انا اكلمت مرتين قبل كده في
تيركس مره كان في امستردام ومره في كوستا
ريكا فدي اول مره اتكلم في تيركس في مصر
ومبسوطه جدا واول مره اتكلم في تيركس في
العربي وعايزه اقوللكم حاجه عن الموضوع
العربي ده العربي بتاعي مكسر كتير عشان
انا عشت بره كتير فلو اتزنقت الكلمه او
كلمتين وقلتها بالانجليزي معلش سموني وطلب
منكم تتهبل
كده انا بطلت موضوع الصحافه من زمان
وابتديت في سنه
2001 كتابه مواضيع الراي وبطلت موضوع
الصحافه عشان انا كنت عايشه في الولايات
المتحده ف في سياتل مدينه سياتل لما حصل
موضوع 11 سبتمبر وهرجع تاني للموضوع ده
قبل بعد شويه بس عايزه ابتدي بموضوع 11
سبتمبر
وموضوع العنف السياسي وموضوع كلمه الارهاب
عشان كلمه الارهاب كلمه صعبه وقليل جدا
لما انا بستعمل كلمه الارهاب عشان كلمه
الارهاب دايما بتستعمل او عت بتستعمل
استعمال سياسي لو حد احنا بنكره عمل عنف
يبقى ارهابي لو حد احنا بنحبه مارس عنف
يبقى
كويس فمن حوالي اسبوع انا كنت قاعده في
الصالون عندي انا ساكنه في القاهره وسمعت
صوت تقريبا كان انت فيجار بس ما كنتش
عارفاك ايه فلما الموضوع ده بيحصل وبيحصل
كتير قوي الايام دي في القاهره اول حاجه
بنعملها بندخل على تويتر يا جماعه حد سمع
الصوت ده ونص التام بتاعي كان بيقول يا
جماعه حد سمع الصوت ده وعرفنا بعد خمس
دقاق ان حصل انفجار على كوبري 15 مايو
اللي هو من ناحيه شارع 26 يوليو وانا
ساكنه في حي الزمالك جنب شارع 26 يوليو
وبسمع العربيات وهي ماشيه على كبري 15
مايو وشارع 26 يونيو فسمعت الصوت ده وكان
واضح
جدا وبعديه قبليها بحوالي شهر شهر ونص كده
كنت بزور اهلي كنت بزور ماما وبابا وانا
وبابا كنا سهرانين شويه انا على الكمبيوتر
وهو بيقرا حاجه على الواتساب والفيسبوك
والحاجات دي كلها وفي خلال 10 دقائق
سمعنا صوتين الاتنين طلعوا
انفجارين اليوم ده كان اليوم اللي هو
اتغير فيه وزير الداخليه وحصل التغيير
الوزاري ده في الاسبوع قبل الفجرين دول
اللي هم كانوا بعد بعض ب 10 دقاق كان ممكن
اقوللكم كم انفجار بالضبط حصل في القاهره
وكان ممكن ا اقوللكم بالضبط كانكم واحد
اتقتل في قسم
المطريه بعد حصل بعد موضوع تعذيب ا في
القسم هناك وكان والحاجات دي كلها موجوده
من منظمات حقوق الانسان والصحافه المصريه
والعالميه تكتب عنها وكان ممكن اقول لكم
كمان في الاسبوع ده كم وزير اتغير
والاسامي الجديده والاسامي القديمه اللي
ماشيت اللي هو بقى اللي انا ما كنتش اقدر
اقول لكم ايه كم واحده جوزها ضربها في
البيت كم بنت حصل لها
ختم كم واحده حصل لها تعرش تحرش او عنف
جنسي في الشارع في اي منطقه في الكهن رغم
ان احنا عارفين الحاجات دي بتحصل كتير وفي
كل يوم وفي كل لحظه اشمعنى انا ممكن اقول
لكم كم انتظار حصل وكم واحد مات في قسم
المطريه وكم وزير اشال وكم وزير جديد جاه
ليه بن بنسمي اللي بيحصل بره في الشارع
ارهاب وليه ما بنسمي اللي بيحصل في البيت
ارهاب ضد المراه ليه ما بنسمي العنف
الجنسي والتحرش الجنسي اللي بيحصل في كل
شوارع مصر وكل بنت وكل واحده في في الصاله
هنا ممكن تقول لكم ان حصلها ليه ما بنسمي
ده ارهاب جنسي ليه ما بنسمي الختال اللي
هو حصل ل
91% من الانثى في مصر بين سن 15 و49
91% الختان ارهاب ضد جسد البنت الختان
مالهوش اي فوايد طبيه الختان بيدمر حياه
المراه في مصر ليه ماسموش هاب لو جنا
وشفنا كلمه ارهاب دي معناها ايه عنف الهدف
بتاع العنف ده ان هو يخليك تغير اسلوب
حياتك انا اكلمت عن موضوع 11 سبتمبر في
نويورك بعد ما
حصل الهجومات اللي حصلت في نيويورك واشن
دي سي وفيلادلفيا وفي بوستن ايه اللي حصل
كنا بنروح روح المطار واقلع الجزمه واقلع
الجاكيت ومافيش
ميه ولازم كل حاجه تدخل في الشنطه قد كده
وحاجات ان غيرنا اسلوب حياتنا تماما عشان
موضوع
الارهاب فاللي بيمارس دد المراه والبنت في
مصر من الختان ان واحد يضرب مراته او واحد
يضرب بنته او اخص يضرب اخته ارهاب واللي
بيحصل في الشارع ارهاب وده حدث وقي ل انا
بكون ماشيه في الشارع وحد بيقوللي حاجه
على شعر شعري بيحصل كل خمس دقاق صدقوني او
حد لمسني في حته في جسمي من غير
اذني او حد حاول يعتدي عل في الشارع كل
الحاجات دي بتحصل ليه هدفها ايه هدفها من
الرساله ان الاماكن اللي بره دي بتاع
الراجل في مصر وانا مكاني فين انا مكاني
في البيت بس ايه اللي بيحصل لي في البيت
انا لسه قايله لكم اهو الختان وضرب الزوجه
والعنف منزل فمعناه ان البنت والمرا
المراه عامه في مصر بتواجه ارهاب في البيت
وبره البيت بس عمرنا ما بنسميه ارهاب
ليه انا اكلمت عن الصحافه العالميه
والصحافه المصريه وزاي هم بيتكلموا عن
الانفجارات والتعذيب في الاقسام والحاجات
دي كلها لما الواحد بيقرا الاخبار وانا
كنت صحفيه سنين كتير انا كنت صحفيه مع
وكاله انباء ز معديان وحاجات
كتير دايما اللي بيحصل بره وال حصل في
السياسه مواضيع الرجاله حكايات الرجاله
فلان الرئيس عمل وفلان وزير رئيس الوزرا
عمل وفلان وزير الدفاع قال كل الحاجات دي
مواضيع وقصص الرجاله واحنا كشعب في اي
مكان في العالم مش في مصر بس اتعودنا ان
هي دي الحكايات اللي هي مهمه ان احنا كلنا
لازم نركز فيها بس المراه نص المجتمع مش
مهمه ليه الارهاب اللي بيحصل ضدها في
المنزل او بره المنزل مش مهم ليه وتاني
برجع اقول ليه ما بنسميه ارهاب تتكلم
دلوقتي عن ارهاب حصلي انا شخصيا عشان انا
مؤمنه جدا بموضوع القصه الشخصيه عشان لو
انا كاتبه انا بطلت موضوع صحا زي ما
قلتلكم ودلوقتي بكتب عواميد را وابتديت
اكتب اكتر واكت عن حياتي الشخصيه ليه
بتكلم اكتر واكتر عن حياتي الشخصيه لما
كنت صحفيه لو اي حد هنا في الرساله معانا
صحفي هي او هو هيقول لك او هيقول لك ان
عمر ما بيحصل ان صحفي او صحفيه بتتكلم عن
حياتها الشخصيه عشان احنا داما بنتكلم عن
الحاجات اللي بره الحاجات المهمه الحاجات
السياسيه ليه حياتي انا الشخصيه مش مهمه
فانا لما ابتديت موضوع عواميد الراي دي
ابتديت بقى استعمل كلمه انا احنا عارفين
دايما بنقول اعوذ بالله من كلمه انا بس
عشان نقصر حاج ان اللي بيحصل بره ده ارهاب
واللي بيحصل جوه ده البنت والست مش ارهاب
لازم كل بنت وكل ست تبتدي تقول انا وتقول
انا بثقه وتقول انا عشان انا مهمه فحك لكم
شويه عن اللي حصلي واللي حصلي للاسف مش ما
حصليش انا بس حصل لناس كتير او ستات كتير
بس للاسف مش قادرين او لسه ما وصلوش
لمرحله ان هم يقدروا يقولوا انا ف ح قلي
في مظاهرات محمد محمود في شهر نوفمبر 2011
ان انا وزميل ليا ناشط سياسي ضمينا
للمظاهرات وانا كنت بصور بالتليفون بتاعي
وصلنا لقدام خالص ش محمد محمود انا كنت
طالبه في الجامعه الامريكيه في الشارع ده
انا كنت اعرفه كويس جدا و مضيت سنين كتير
من حياتي في الشارع ده ف كان بيحصل مظاهره
كبيره زي محمد محمود قعدت خمس ايام انا
وقتها كنت بره مصر كان المفروض اروح اتكلم
في في البرلمان
الاوروبي براسلز في بروكسل وكان المفروض
اروح اتكلم هناك عن المراه والثوره بس انا
لما ابتديت اقرا عن اللي بيحصل في محمد
محمود ودخول الاوز وانا بحب الاوز قوي
وعندي اصحاب كتير في التراز اهلاوي والتز
واي نايت اول ما شفت ان الراز دخلوا واول
ما شفت ان ناس كتير دخلوا واول ما شفت سبب
مظاهره محمد محمود ايه ان في ناس من اعضاء
الامن راحوا ميدان التحرير وحرقوا خيم
وضربوا اهالي الشهدا طبعا زي ما كتير ما
ان انا حاس زعلت جدا وكنت بقعد وقتها كنت
في المغرب قبل ما اروح بلجيكا كنت ما
بنامش وطول الوقت على تويتر وبعيط واشوف
صور طالعه من محمد محمود فلغيت رحله
بلجيكا وقررت ان انا هاجي مصر عشان اضم
للمظاهر محمد محمود وفعلا ورحت زي ما قلت
مع زميلي اللي هو الناشط السياسي
اتمسكنا بناس مندسين ناس كانوا لابسين
زينا عادي كانوا عاملين كانهم هم في
المظاهره معانا مسكونا في محل كده بتاع
حلويات لغايه ما الامن المركزي جا لما
الامن المركزي ج فجاه لقيت قبل ما الامن
المركزي يجي ايه اللي حصل واحد من المدين
كان بيحاول يشد التليفون يد
والتاني حطت ايده على صدري انا اتجننت
عشان في الاول افتكرت ان الناس طول معانا
في المظاهره وما كانش داخل مخي ازاي بيحصل
لي عنف جنسي والامن المركزي جاي وبيضربوا
علينا نار حيه والاخ الافندي اللي واقف
جنبي ده خطر على باله ان واحده واقفه
قدامي وهمسك صدرها ازاي ففهمت بعدين بقى
اللي هو من الامن بس امن او مش امن زي ما
قلت كل واحده في الصاله هنا ممكن تقول لكم
كم مره في اليوم بيحصلها عنف جنسي او تحرش
في الشارع في مصر اللي هو انا مصممه ان
اسميه ارهاب فلما مسك الاخ ده صدري انا
مخي طعار نزلت فيه ضرب عمري في حياتي ما
ضربت حد زي ما ضربت الاخ ده وزميل الناشط
السياسي ده كان شايف الامن المركزي وهم
جايين وقعد يشد فيا يقول لي منى مش وقته
منى مش وقته قولوا مصممه ان لازم اعلموا
الدرس ده عشان ازاي يعمل في كده اخيرا بقى
لما جوم الامن المركزي كلهم هربوا فقيت ان
هو مع الامن وهو كمان هرب افتكرت ان زميلي
قدر يهرب بس اتضح لي بعدين ان الامن
المركزي خدوه الناحيه الثانيه من الشارع
حطه ايديه ورا ظهره ولزه في ضرب كان احتاج
بعدين ان هو يروح المستشفى عشان وشه وخد
كذا غرزه وقفوا في مكان وهو بيتدرب وهو
شايف هم بيعملوا فييها ايه الناحيه
الثانيه فكان حواليا حوالي اربعه او خمسه
من الامن المركزي كل واحد ماسك عصايه قد
كده ونزلين في ضرب وانا عشان احمي دماغي
حطيت دراعتي كده فدعي الشمال اتكسر وايدي
اليمين كسرت من ناحيتين وبعدين خدوني في
مكان كده مجهور بين صفنا احنا وصف الامن
اللي هو كان جنب وزاره الدخليه واعتدوا
عليا جنسيا وبعد ما حصل الموضوع ده وكنت
بشيل بقى ايدين من البنطلون وايدين من على
صدري ومعلش انا اسفه انا بتكلم بصراحه جدا
عشان لازم نتكلم بصراحه جدا في المواضيع
دي عشان مصممه وبصر تاني وبكرر ان الحاجات
دي ارهاب ارهاب ضد جسد المراه وبعدين
شدوني لوزاره الداخليه قبل ما ادخل وزاره
الداخليه خدوني للضابط اللي هو البي
بتاعهم بقى الضابط ده بيقول لي ايه ما
تقلقيش انا هحميكي هحمي لي ازاي هو بقى
واقف قدامي كده وهم لسه ايديهم من تحت من
كل حته ما بيعملش ولا حاجه بسز اسمي
بحميكي وقال لي لول اللي انا موجود انت
عارفه كان عملي فيكي ايه
وبيشاور كده وناس تمين الامن المركزي
عاملين كده كانهم بقى خلاص جاهدين يجوا
بقى يقطعوا فيه ده الح حما بعديها اتحجزت
في وزاره الداخليه ست ساعات وبعدين ست
ساعات في المخابرات العسكريه قعدت ساعتين
مغمضين عينيا وبقى سينجو جينجو سينجو جين
لغايه ما اخيرا افرجوا عليا افرجوا عني
افرجوا عني ليه انا لما كنت بتضرب ف محمد
محمود لما دعتي اكسرت التليفون وقع من
ايدي التليفون ده زي ما انتم شايفين ما
بمشيش في اي مكان من غيره عشان التليفون
ده وتويتر انقذوا حياتي كذا مره اي حد
ناشط سياسي او اي حد قدام المظاهرات فاهم
يعني ايه او فاهمه يعني ايه التليفون
وتويتر انقذوا حياتي فلما تليفوني دعوا
وهم بيضربوني وكسروا دعتي لما كنت في
الداخليه بقى قعدت لاث ساعات مش قادره
اقول للعالم اللي بره ده ايه اللي حصل لي
وطول تفكيري بقى ماما وبابا واهلي اكيد
هيتجننوا عشان مش عارفين ايه اللي حصل
اخيرا بعد لاث ساعات جا ناشط من التحرير ك
جاي يتكلم عن حاجه تانيه فوقتها بقى كان
زهقوا مني شويه فرحت قعدت جنبه قلت له
ممكن تدخلني على تدخلني تويتر دخلني تويتر
على البلاك بيري بتاعه بعتت تويت قلت ان
انا اضت و ممسوكه في وزاره الداخليه
وبعديه والله العظيم بعديها بنص دقيقه
البطاريه بتاعه التليفون خلصت فانا دلوقتي
مش عارفه ايه اللي كان هيحصل لو بطاريه
الراجل ده ما كانتش شغاله مش عارفه بس انا
عارفه ان التويت اللي انا بعتها دي فعلا
انقذت حياتي ومش التويت بس انا لما كنتش
الصحفيه محوي ان في ناس تعرفها يعني لو
كنت بنت عاديه واحده عاديه في مصر كده
ماحدش يعرفها ايه اللي كان ممكن يحصل لي
كان حد هيجيلي كان حد هي ينقذني كان حد
كانوا هيفرقوا عني لو انا كده مش معروفه
ومش واقفه هنا على المسرح قدامكم ما
تعرفوش مطحي كانت مع مع روتز الى اخته الى
اخه
مافتكرش فانا رغم كل اللي حصللي ده محظوظه
جدا يعني انا انا الحمد لله ان انا
طلعت بتكلم على الموضوع ده وبتكلم مضوع ده
بصراحه عشان تاني بقول العنف اللي بيمارس
ضد المراه عنف في المنزل عنف في الشارع
ختان عنف جنسي نوع من الارهاب ولازم نسميه
ارهاب انا بعد ما ابتديت اتكلم في الموضوع
ده لقيت ان في بنات كتير حصل لهم موضوع
عنف جنسي بالذات ومش قادرين يتكلموا عنه
ولقيت من منظمه نسويه في القاهره اسمها
نظره للدراسات
النسويه انا اعرف ناس بيشتغلوا هناك بس هم
كتبوا لي وقالوا لي ان الموضوع اللي حصل
معاكي ده حصل مع 12 واحده تانيه بس مش
قادرين يتكلم مش قادرين يتكلموا ليه انا
قلت لكم ان ان تفسير الارهاب ان هو
عنف هدف ان هو يغير طريقه حياتك فالبنات
دي عارفين لو اتكلموا وقالوا ان موضوع
العنف الجنسي ده حصل لهم عيب وشرف ومش
عارف ايه والكلام الكبير ده اللي احنا
بنستعمله عشان نسكت البنت رغم كل اللي
حصلها ده مصممين ان احنا نكتها ليه بدل ما
نقول ان حصل لها ده ارهاب وبدل ما بنتكلم
عن الارهاب ده زي ما انا بتكلم عن
الانفجارات والتعذيب في قسم المطريه كل
الحاجات دي غلط وانا ضد كل الحاجات دي بس
العنف الجنسي والارهاب اللي بيحصل لما
نختن البنات
والارهاب اللي بيحصل في الشارع في صفه
التحرش اللي بيحصل ده كل ده برض مش بس
هدفه ان هو يغير طريقه حياتنا ك بنات او
ستات في مصر بي سجدنا كمان فانا لما اخترت
ان انا اتكلم في الموضوع ده معاكم كنت
مصممنا كمان ان احنا لازم نسال نفسنا امتى
هنبتدي نتكلم ونغطي الحاجات تغطيه صحفيه
عشان اقدر اقرا الجنان او اشوف نشره
الاخبار على التلفزيون واسمع في النشره ان
كذا واحده حصل لها عنف جنسي واتقبض على
جوزها وكذا بنت كان هيحصل لها ختان بس في
اخر لحظه انقذوها عشان باباها كان عايزها
تتختن ومامتها ما كانتش موافقه امتى هقرا
في الجرنان ان كذا واحد فلان وفلان اتقبض
عليهم في الشارع عشان مسكوا واحده من غير
اسمها حط ايدها في مكان من غير اذن او قال
لي كلمه
قيحه انتتى هقرا الحاجات دي في الجرنان
فانا ككاتب وباسمي نفسي كاتبه نسويه انا
لازم اكتب عن الحاجات دي عشان انا لو
مابتدتش ماحدش تاني يبتدي فانا
برجوك بنت او ولد راجل او ست كلنا مصريين
احنا ابتدينا في مصر ثوره سياسيه كلنا
اللي نازل الثوره نزلنا مع بعض ضد نظام
قمعي بس لما روحنا البيت بقى النظام
القمعي في البيت حاجه تانيه النظام القمعي
ده بتاع الدوله قمعي ضدنا كلنا بس احنا ك
انثى او مراه في مصر النظام القمعي ده
البيت الشا والدوله كلهم مع بعض فلازم
نبتدي نسمي الحاجات دي ارهاب ولازم نبتدي
نقول انا مهمه وقصتي مهمه
اشكركم